welcome to frenemies today
possibly more enemies than friends i
came out the gate with the attitude
uh you had the attitude this morning you
didn't tell me what we were doing i had
my full glam i had
so much work to do today with my full
makeup and i was in a
really pissy mood um but then i had to
go home film only fans had a big orgasm
so i feel like you did that
all in the gap i scored it and it hit
the camera i showed moses it
stopped recording with my squirt like
that's how powerful it was
did you have to go and click like record
again yeah
well i did it myself he was upstairs
because i was in a bad mood you know so
i was just like i'm doing it myself nice
and then we had a haunted
mukbang and i was i was miserable i've
just been miserable the whole time and
i'm still miserable because
you just [ __ ] up my whole day and why
didn't i [ __ ] up your whole job that
energy and i didn't like oh my god
you're so annoying
she walks in the door i'm like hey
trisha moses
and then she goes you're in such a bad
mood i could tell i was like what the
[ __ ] i was happy to see you it's
not easy and then you left and then you
came back and you're like i'm still in a
bad mood because of the way you greeted
me i'm like
okay no that's not about moses it's just
because like
no whatever it's like you could talk
about it go ahead get it out and open
nope i learned my lesson it's just like
no
but anyways i just don't i don't
appreciate just your bad energy towards
me and when i didn't actually do
anything
and if you have bad energy towards me
should tell me what i did wrong
rather than hold it in i don't have bad
energy i was happy to see
i brought hanukkah presents i was stoked
i was like cool you your [ __ ]
brain is wired you i was not happy
you came in and you're like i'm gonna
drop this [ __ ] on ethan no matter how he
greets me you're like short of ethan
being like
trisha it's trisha everybody
i'm not that kind of person that's how
you are right now i have never greeted
anybody like that in my life you told
moses i came in i'm just here to do a
show i'm like he's your [ __ ] family
like we should talk about it you're like
no because i'm not here to get in if
moses
and ela have a problem i don't have a
problem with most problems i don't i
sense it most of you have to tell me he
doesn't say anything but i just know
okay so you're psychic from the
beginning from the beginning of our
relationship you're just like wow i'm
just so disappointed this is moses's
fault this is moses the thing like
literally he didn't say that about
anything he literally what did i say
about it what are they saying about he
you literally said that you're so pissed
and it's moses you know what why do you
always bringing up family drama can you
just move on and talk about something
else bring it up
because you're coming in here like oh
because i'm so pissy i don't have bad
energy my energy is pristine
i have beautiful light and perfect
radiant energy
your energy's [ __ ] up girl talk to the
hand
happy hanukkah everybody it starts
december 10th
this thursday um
we had some latkas just now we ordered
those oh you did
we had latkes we had chicken liver ew um
chicken liver yeah and then do you know
how were the latkes though they were
delicious
are you noodle eating latkes no we did
potatoes
we had jelly donut i put one of these at
me for my only fans today so it squirted
jelly inside my
you squirted it inside yeah i was like
and then you squirted that in your vag
the juice
it went inside me and then out me how
did you squirt it out
i squirted it out oh so so before you
orgasm you squirted jelly in your vag
so i pushed it up me first the whole
donut or just the jelly the jelly
okay and then i went off and squirted it
out
that doesn't sound healthy to get like a
donut in your vagina i mean i don't know
but like can't
can you get an infection i don't know i
guess we'll find out
i used to do people like that when you
squirt like food out of your vag and
[ __ ]
well just because it'll like color like
it's pink you know oh okay
do you have powdered sugar on me a
little bit on your lips
that's gnarly pink um anyways i it
because you just didn't tell me like i
was saying i feel like i'm a guest on
the show you didn't tell me we were
doing stuff with myself well
okay to be fair i did tell you we were
going to do this a few days ago but you
don't ever listen and you have no
involvement right now
you could take a thousand dollars if you
did you if you you show me i'll give you
a thousand dollars if you don't then you
give me a thousand dollars there's no
way you can okay
that's fair i mean you've given me
you've given me money over the years
all right first of all or over the
months okay let me scroll up because we
have a private one and we have
we have um a personal one but let me see
if i can find it
um as i look i have a gift for you
actually i have multiple gifts for you
but your big one comes next week because
it's halfway through hanukkah wait we're
doing gift exchange already i thought we
would do it on christmas cause i didn't
buy anything for you yet um i have
multiple things for you
oh [ __ ] because it's i was so i you
wanna you wanna open up the first one
right now
it's my wedding absolutely yeah yeah
yeah i'm so sorry yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is like this is
like a joint one this isn't the cool one
i have a really cool one coming from
here okay this looks great thank you so
much well it's like a joint gift
it's like for both of us from you and
moses no it's for both of us
why is it for both of us it better not
be some weird ass [ __ ]
i'm not sharing anything with you right
now you'll see why in a minute i got
something for you though
like personally but interesting odor oh
wow
be careful did we bring
the yeah
yo you got a blinged out frenemy's
menorah yeah
i love it thanks thank you that's so
cool
we brought candles away oh my god well
we can't desecrate hanukkah
and not we have to wait until hanukkah
and then we can do oh we lit all eight
of them today
oh you're going to hell i'm kidding
you just don't even care about hanukkah
there's not enough
there's only seven so some have seven
some have eight
it's oh that is weird yeah some because
there's eight days but sometimes the
center ones just for lighting the other
ones
right but this one is just you don't
you don't get the center so we can't
light it all right well there you go
this is so
amazing i'm i'm actually really touched
that this is a really thoughtful cool
gift
i got something really cool for you but
it's not in yeah i almost brought it i
would have brought it today but i got
something
really cool well i have to go i gotta no
you don't have to no i am i am i was
waiting for christmas because you're
maybe on christmas i'll do the okay i'll
do it because i need some time to think
of something perfect
i i have a big gift giver i love gift
giving and when people don't give me
gifts back i get really like annoyed
even though i don't i pretend like i'm
not
yeah i know i know that's what but i but
i might always
my intention was to get you a really
epic gift i got you an epic gift but i
okay i don't want to say is it a rose
rice
that's what i really want um no but i i
you know what i do when i want a gift i
like say it on tick-tock because i know
moses has watched all my tic-tacs so i'm
like i really
had a point that's some real
crazy like and guess what i got a
diamond necklace from it
let me see oh [ __ ] oh the the star david
no this one right here but then he buy
that one when he was like when you guys
broke up and he was like
no take me back this is a broke-up the
diamond's a breakup one he got me a hand
of god when we broke up
which is the new one this is the new one
and then he got me the hand one
you're gonna be [ __ ] broke moses you
better be careful buying her ass all
these diamonds he's been saving his
money his whole life
yeah he's not gonna have anything at the
end of this [ __ ]
i'll take care of him though because you
know when people give me gifts like if
they go broke by me guess i'll take care
of him you know what if
you guys break up i mean hypothetically
i know you don't want to think about
that but would you return the jewelry
tan
no no oh thanks yeah no you don't return
jewelry
i don't know i don't buy girl's jewelry
i ever have no i thought
i bought ela but she doesn't seem like
two different girls you know what i mean
yeah i don't think i would ever survive
with a girl like you definitely not
no i'd get eaten alive can i try one of
these
yeah that's brittle it looks great you
can't stand what
say it guys like you yeah well [ __ ] you
because you're so like
i don't mind buying jewelry i buy ela
whatever she wants but i pre but like i
just
the whole concept of jewelry is just
kind of odd i want you to want to buy me
jewelry i don't want to have to tell you
i want jewelry i buy it
i buy ela gifts i buy ela nice gifts
it's just she doesn't like jewelry
so then that's it yeah i buy her nice
gifts moses doesn't like gifts so like
i don't ever know what to get i'm gonna
probably be like get like a mclaren or
something
a mclaren but he already has a nice car
oh that's some sugar daddies here right
there
i'm gonna clear him you guys better save
your mind you got a house now
i'm like killing it now that i'm doing
posting every day and only fans like i
was kind of like slapping and now i'm
kind of killing it
okay keep it up and i got these two
these have little star of david's and
menorahs on it
this is it is it this is mozzarella this
is everything
see you're in a better mood now i say
that food everything
i say that me and niela say that at home
around every all the time now
this is everything we do
wow you're like a little boy you look
like an overgrown toddler today
why because of the hat and maybe and the
teddy fresh is throwing me off a little
bit today
it's not like swaggy like you normally
wear them
if you're grown taller i'll take it as
long as you don't want to [ __ ] me i'll
do anything to be less
physically attractive too literally
don't even want to joke about that
anymore because it makes me actually
nauseous you know what
they have a saying in hebrew ani
you make me sick you do it i do good
let's keep it that way did i say it
right
aniola of course you know that
you got this relationship so [ __ ] up
you know so little hebrew but you know
you make me sick
but it actually means like sick and love
but you can also say like oh you make me
sick that's what you told me
that's the way you express it anyways
you're away from the mic
let me ask you questions asmr okay i
kind of love it i mean i'm not gonna lie
i was gonna say we should talk about
youtube but obviously i like talking
about me more
well we've talked about you let's move
on how's your week been
um it's been really great a lot of
people have been getting covered this
week
so i'm sure like everyone i see i only
see like five people but they all got
copenhagen
they just get protested anyways for me
but everyone i know has been getting
involved
i saw that yeah no but same thing
happened with one of my really close
friends like doesn't see anyone got it
and so i was i was a little paranoid
everyone's been getting it i was just
like but but we're
you know what's crazy what not to talk
about cover because people are over here
everybody on the show
but in california we're like 95 percent
full
the hospitals like that it's bad
i wear a mask we're math people
okay let's talk our the main thrust of
our episode here today
is we're going to be trying celebrity
beauty treatments
and some of the [ __ ] that these
celebrities do is weird as hell
did you get the foreskin you know what
i made a conscious decision not to do
that because i don't support the
harvesting of children's foreskin
you know what i mean it's just weird
that they have like foreskin factories
where they
farm it are you gonna get adult foreskin
see
that's you couldn't claim that that was
uncr
uncruelly harvested but at least the
babies they have like farms where the
baby's foreskins grow like super long
they're like mutated humans
and they farm the foreskins it's like
super inhumane what'd you do with
theodorous foreskin i think they just
threw it out
i'd probably eat my own sons why would
you eat it
it does something for you i forget what
it makes you a freak forever
yeah the placenta some women eat not the
foreskin for christ's sake what in god's
name
i put it on my face wait what did they
do with the
i put it on foreign son's face on his
face that's so cruel that's like
this is so sick all right let's talk
let's i really do enjoy doing this
podcast but like
you just pissed me off like so much
because you just everything just didn't
tell me
you know just everything pissed me off
this morning just tell me when we're
doing stuff i feel like you're just
things are just pissing you off i don't
think i have nothing to do with me full
hair makeup like i'm a
full-time porn i'm a full-time tic
talker i'm a full-time like other things
that i got to do after this and now i
can't do any of it which is fine
we already went home and did all of it
but just tell them yeah you came and i
was like oh well you want to go home and
do it and then you came back and now
we're going to do
30 minutes home 30 minutes here 30
minutes home like we wasted an hour and
a half just driving here today
well [ __ ] happens trisha i mean what the
[ __ ]
i did tell you by the way which i will
wait find it
i don't have time because i gotta look
but like come on we're trying to do a
show here not [ __ ]
prove trisha wrong episode did we say it
was sponsored i mean we wouldn't have to
say that oh sponsored by adam
and eve thank you he's code h3 he's
called age three exactly
okay so you died on twitter apparently
what was that about that was that when i
was here
really i missed all of it because i was
here during the podcast rip
trisha was trending i don't get it
though was it rip trisha was like
something or is it r.i.p
trisha it was r.i.p trisha i didn't get
it
i like missed all of it i was like what
i think people were just goofing that
you died i don't know what was the
origin of it
i have no idea i love it though honestly
if i there's a death hoax about me
like i like being relevant like well
it's interesting that people cared
enough about you to kill you
do you know what's awful though it's
like literally all the tweets are like
haha thank god that [ __ ] is dead i was
like oh my god
it was really sad it like kind of
depressed me well but it's got to feel
good in a way that like
you would even be trending if you that's
what i'm saying yeah i was like well
that's because
you seem to be obsessed with your death
and like how it will impact the world
for sure for sure that i keep saying i
don't want i have a girl that really
hates me online and i think she'll
probably
murder me and i told moses how sucky
it's gonna be that she's gonna be part
of my life story forever
so if they make a movie about me that
girl gets to be tied in with me this
girl
you better protect yours you're why you
keep willing this girl to kill you just
stop talking she's about
you're like don't kill me she's coming
around don't kill me you can be part of
my life story
you want her to kill you with selena
like yolanda you literally want her to
kill you
i do not well
you feel trapped in this relationship
don't you you're like begging for
someone to murder you
no actually i've never been more in love
and we have sucked so much now again and
it's oh you're back
when you're back on yeah it's good i'm
happy i like just like being bent over
the couch and getting real cause you
dress so hard
oh you're a hard thruster wow because of
my bed is so soft so he doesn't thrust
as hard but now that we've been doing it
over the couch i'm like oh this is good
so like i
get so horny excellent all the time
excellent good i've been so happy i'm
happy for you i'm sitting i'm not
gonna do that do you just like bend you
over and rail her on the couch
uh maybe at one point a while ago but
there's no railing or
there's no railroading or anything like
that she would like i shouldn't talk
about them
i don't know i'm chilling for tomorrow
guys but i i think she would like it
because she's so
boss babe right she's so like
independent like controls everything
like you know that's how i am so
sometimes you like to just
have no control over how hard you're
getting pounded
i'll pass that feedback to her and see
how and see if she'll see what she's up
for i bet she's a submissive because
usually people who are so dominant
independent in real life there are subs
and
yeah she's more submissive in the
bedroom
you know i like to role play like i'm
moses high school girlfriend so we do
like hebrew
like we speak like hebrew i'm like what
would you say like during sex in hebrew
and it's like can
can odd uh that doesn't sound very
romantic
it's like what the [ __ ] you saying do it
like i'll be like talk to me like you
talk to your high school girlfriend in
hebrew and he like
laughs why don't you do that he says
he says it's too funny but i'm like i
like to like you know be like he'll do
it but then he like laughs he's like oh
like let's go upstairs here i have a
role play
idea for you guys your mossad agent
and she's from hamas you like that
what's hamas
they're the terrorists in palestine you
cannot make palestine jokes i had to
delete my tic tacs people were still
offended by my palestine joke
i have that in here we can talk about it
but that would be that would be a fun
role play
mossad is like the cia in israel uh-huh
and then you would be like a terror like
a palestinian terrorist
you have to like grow my bush out to be
hairy like a beard ask him it's your
guy's fantasy
i like that i love a little hebrew
roleplay
are you into that moses anything
anything for you he says
okay our relationship is like bomb right
now like it actually has never been
better someone wrote an obituary
did you know that you have an obituary
no really
was american media personality model
actress and singer
peda's sister has said she began
experiencing signs of mental illness her
mother lenapeta said her daughter died
of the novel coronavirus
oh my god i'm dying of kobe that's june
11th you died at 32 years
wait dude 11 but it just happened this
past week you died before that
oh from from corona corona
notable youtubers showed their
grievances shane dawson
fiance ryland adams said my thoughts are
with her family during this difficult
time
even ex-boyfriend jason nash says i
can't even bring myself to understand
she's not here anymore literally would
be so happy that i stopped talking about
him
paid his sister and mother asked for
strength and guidance during these times
and they're having a candlelight vigil
which will be held at saint francis of
rome catholic church and
will wildemar you know that player
pedes is survived by her mother her dad
her sister and her brother i know you
have a brother i do have a brother he
never likes me to mention him period
oh well we [ __ ] up really what does he
do
because he's so mysterious he's like a
yeah he's pretty bougie job but i can't
say anything
he literally would kill me yeah he
wouldn't kill me literally but
he has a very high-end high-profile job
good for him
yeah he kills it
that's not much of an obituary you i
think you'd be pissed by that
like they didn't well yeah that's some
[ __ ]
it promoted saint francis of rome though
that's my dad's church that he like
speaks at um let's see
dixie's dixie's new song you
memed on oh it's gonna get clean but it
basically goes
one day one day i was really really
really really sad
yeah that's it honestly it's kind of a
bop moses was seeing it the other day
he's like i can't it's been stuck in my
head because everyone on tick tock is
making fun of it
it's every that's so smart though like
low-key i feel like they wanted to that
to happen
he's making fun of how bad it is i can't
get over that macho
it's so good oh good oh i'm glad we
brought the thing is though
if she wanted it to be bad why did she
erase her trailer and disgrace
no i think they i think if i think i
don't think they wanted it to but if
they were smart they'd be like oh [ __ ]
everyone's listening to this song
because the mom went on instagram live
and was like how dare you guys
like she's 19. yeah she's 19 and she's
on tick tock of course everyone's gonna
clown on her
yeah one day one day
i was really really really really sad
yeah
that is a bop i like it i mean it
conveys
a lot yeah sadness for one one day
one day beat depression in one day one
specific day yeah
wouldn't that be nice it's just one day
one day
okay so there was that the notes so
here's the israeli-palestine conflict
summarized by tricia
wait you erased it because this is a
link to your tick tock um i think i put
it back up i asked moses if it was okay
if i put it back up i didn't want to
embarrass him further
so the caption is when you take your
boyfriend's israeli identity and all the
comments are free palestine
and you're just trying to figure out
where palestine even is and why it needs
to be freed i mean it's funny how
willing
you are to be ignorant but it's true
they always say free passing i'm like
i swear when i met him i'm like what
does that even mean like what is
palestine like i had no idea
i think it's the way that you do it is
like
trip you're making fun of them literally
no
no because i don't even know what it's
about i watched zohan and i was like i
don't understand this like
zohan is not a documentary but it is
about palestine versus israel
do you did you tell her anything about
it moses
well we don't you want me to tell you a
little bit i can give you in a nutshell
i get it i get it well people always get
mad at me because they go oh you make a
phone number because you're in here and
then you don't explain it to her doesn't
know you're gonna educate me on it i can
give you in a nutshell
okay okay here we go
so before the there before there was a
mass
immigration of jews from europe and
around the world to israel
there was the palestinians lived there
more or less this is very simplified
and then the jews bought up a ton of
land and moved them
and just kind of forced them in a lot of
ways down into
the west bank and the gaza strip
some people consider all of israel
palestine uh
but it's like traditionally palestine i
mean it is if you go back at a map it
will used to be called palestine
palestinian territory so if i go to
israel i can walk into palestine
well palestine is is kind of it's not
palestine in israel is kind of a name
for the same place so
everything is so jaffa is palestine
yeah if you ask a palestinian they'll
say it's palestine
so he could say he's palestinian no
because he's not arab he's not
palestinian
only arabs believe that well palestinian
is a group of people like jews is a
group of people
so palestinians are are arabs who come
from that region
uh you know their their lineage and
their heritage and their they're from
that region but they
they're living in gaza strip which is
like a really horrible place to live
and uh they're like boxing this tiny bit
of land that israel owns
and uh it's [ __ ] horrible to live
there so they're not like walking around
tel aviv
no well some of our yeah no there's
there's a lot of arab um
uh israeli uh dual citizens i don't want
them to be mad honestly like i really
don't
i thought it was a joke because like
honestly where i was coming from is like
i don't even know where palestine is
like i don't
yeah it's kind of complicated but but
but
palestine there's a lot of you know
the israelis do a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
there like stealing their land
encroaching on their land all the time
they like christopher columbus
yeah they're like christopher columbus
light i would say because they have to
deal with like pr
where christopher columbus was like [ __ ]
these indians dude
he's out there with like polio and
[ __ ] weed whackers
he's like nobody gives a [ __ ] so yeah
they're kind of like christopher
columbus like how did i do dan did i do
okay
i mean i don't try to piss anyone off
here no i'm just trying to eat mozza
brittle
it's hanukkah so we can't piss them off
but obviously um that's why they get
sensitive because
they think it's like a genocide like a
palestinian genocide
oh slash apartheid happening now
yeah right i apologize i think my joke
was funny i think it's a joke with stick
talk
i thought it was funny thanks but it's
more a joke about how ignorant you are
not about the palestinian
people that's how i feel too yeah like
oh my god look at this dumb [ __ ]
i'm not dumb i just like who knows no
one is taught israeli verse palestine i
feel like
the vast majority of people know what
palestine is that's not true
what that's not true why is it not true
because like we were talking about how
he didn't learn about u.s history we
don't learn about israeli history yeah
but
palestinian the whole jew the
israel-palestinian conflict was like one
if not the most like globally
like globally forefront conflict
in the world it's like everybody knows
about that conflict
who do you think that right i don't
think so i don't know do you agree with
me dan
we're all jewish so it's hard i don't
know
no i mean yeah like i mean you guys are
arabs so
oh oh my god both arabs you're
palestinian then they're not palestinian
you guys are lebanese
arabs are palestinians not every arab is
palestinian that's ridiculous
there's tons of countries in in the
middle east
oh i feel some tension now we got some
jews we got some arabs
we got the you just christians
uh jerusalem this is every whoa
sorry does that mean you're muslim arab
is muslim not all of them
but you are yeah ah that's dope no i
love it
i was just saying i want to interview a
muslim like i don't know muslims like
ask them anything we got them right here
well they can't hear them i feel like we
need to have them on as a guest
here can let's say this will be great
there you go
that's [ __ ] crazy do you guys mind
being interviewed
wait trish let's
let's let's learn from an arab here dan
pass off the mic
we're going impromptu baby he's like
[ __ ] i feel like jan just hates
frenemies all the time he's like over it
yeah he does
then so he's like wrap it up wrap it up
h3 goes for three and a half hours
no no no no you gotta follow you gotta
follow what's good dude whenever we have
a chance to educate trisha we have to
take it
so here we have a bee with us our
resident uh
arab muslim hello thank you for being
here can i ask you the first question
yes so trisha says when you sat down
she's like you're really arab that's so
trippy
how does that make you feel because i
know trisha it doesn't bother me no
trisha trish was it odd i get a pass to
ask
but is it odd being treated like an
oddity i mean you're just like a normal
american dude um i know because
i'm kind of used to it growing up uh 9
11 happened when i was like in second
grade
so i heard it a lot like growing up and
was it because like how you look at your
name
is my name what's your name your full
name can you say i don't know i could
say abdullah
abdallah yeah and it's pretty good
i have a this is like a question because
i'm genuinely you're on social media
well you're here now on here
yeah like and you're not scared of
getting like killed like on 90 days
no because like on 90 day fiance as in
could get killed for having social media
he's in jordan oh you're saying because
i'm muslim yeah you know
me on social media and stuff well right
well
i'll let you take it yeah now there's
always like a lot of like uh
[ __ ] that goes around about being
muslim it's not as scary or as
extreme as a lot of people make it it's
just like any other
religion there's extremes you know in
christianity or
oh right if you're in jordan it's way
different he's in america
you and your girlfriend are both
americans they're not even jordanese
they're lebanese
oh that's different so they're not in
that country and they're not
even of that country okay you know what
i mean i know you're dating a muslim but
can you date a non-muslim
um me personally i don't mind but uh
like my dad's side of the family would
mind
they prefer if you how much would they
mind um
like my my parents are more liberal but
like my
uh aunts and uncles they would they
don't
only want like a muslim they want like
the same village the same
oh [ __ ] yeah they prefer same sect of
islam like that's pretty easy
what if everyone from that village is
just kind of like
busted yeah there's some villages like
that are you guys from the same village
uh no we're not but and i noticed close
enough
close enough well because okay she said
you could answer for her too but like i
know she doesn't wear
a head thing and on muslim tic-tock
everybody wears a head wrap and if you
don't
rap yeah so that's another
like common misconception like my uncle
he's very religious and he
taught me everything i know about uh
islam and uh
it comes from an older text and the word
is uh
it's like an ancient word like the book
our holy book is very old and it's not
supposed to be changed at all so
there's a lot of misconceptions
misinterpretation so
um like me like i believe it just means
that a woman is supposed to like dress
modestly um where some people think it's
just covering the hair or something
it's just you know showing the eyes it's
just whatever the interpretation is so
she shows cleave not into it
uh no i don't mind but would you show
cleavage
you would show cleavage no comment
but would you wear a bikini yeah yeah
sure you were leaning use a model yeah
oh really oh a muslim [ __ ]
oh my god that's so interesting what
about like
mia khalifa she's muslim no
okay dude being muslim is like a huge
swath
okay right backstage oh people is like
you have to understand there's like
is this arabic yes whoa what's it say
um the translation is basically keep
moving forward
can you say it in arabic she can no
no they're like no we can't say it okay
no worries so you don't you don't know
how to speak arabic
not well no i know how to swear pretty
much i love that say hello
oh uh shamuta
i know i've dated all the cultures but
you understand that like being a muslim
or being an arab is like a huge swath of
like
as as diverse as being like a christian
or a jew there's people like obviously
he's very secular
but muslims are known to be like heart
like 90 fiance every muslim on there is
like
they're in jordan they're in jordan
don't you understand
even here like they're very hardcore
they cover you this is the first muslim
you've ever or
arab you've ever met in your life you
just said that wow yeah
wow right are you scared of anything
like the
are you scared of anything like them
coming for you for anything
who's coming for him no
your family because it's the family that
like has hate on hate if you're if
you're what do you think happens he gets
stoned maybe
i mean that he literally said we watched
anything he was like they will kill you
my dad will literally kill him
for being on the show like i said yeah
just extremely everything
everyone i know like no extremities like
where i come from my hometown has the
highest uh population
of muslims outside um
i mean in the us right so and like all
my friends are all a bunch of
degenerates they smoke drink and they're
muslims yeah muslims yeah oh so you only
hang out with muslims
no no we don't really see race where i'm
from like we have a lot of we hang out
with a lot of uh
everybody yeah everybody yeah well
that's so interesting i always find it
interesting how
jews do hang out with jews muslims hang
out with muslims israelis meet israelis
you know what i mean like it is kind of
weird how that all happens but i think
that's interesting because he said he
has muslim friends
i've never met muslims so you know what
i mean like it's interesting how they
all find each other and gravitate are
you scared what do you think did you
what do you think where are you i'm so
impressed i'm so
because you have tattoos right we have a
girlfriend i just i
watch wife yeah oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] are you 28 yeah i have three
wives
no i'm kidding oh my god you don't
believe in that but
that's the thing because soldier boy on
98 fiance he could have no more money
too you're not gonna do that that's
another one of those things that we
think is like open to interpretation
like when the book was first made it was
like during a time of war
um family's gonna provide there's a lot
more to it than that
but i don't think it was meant for like
modern day you're not about
wearing multiple women i mean i'm almost
for it but i don't think
oh you're not for it oh
she says he's kidding but he's like i
don't know i'm all for
i kind of like the idea of multiple
wives like i kind of wish you liked that
moses thoughts
all right come on first of all that was
a test so let's listen to that
all right we can do this all day thank
you very much congrats that's so
exciting
congrats on what he made it oh out alive
i guess
he was born in america oh that's crazy
they both don't look muslim to me so
that's why i thought that was so
interesting
what is the muslim supposed to look like
i'll show you on tik tok they wear the
hijabs
i wanted to wear he has a he has a
muslim scarf at home but he won't let me
wear it well he lets me wear it but you
understand they're jordanian
and who's america okay but there's
nigerian muslims there's like so many
different muslims so
lebanese muslims too are from that same
area it's israel different country
but is that same sector of the middle
east
so saudi arabian muslims are the same
as let's say indonesian muslims
i'm asking you no yes yeah okay
i love my saudi fans i have a lot of
people from saudi arabia you do yeah for
real they come to my show awesome
they have money they always have the
vips can we go buddies all right let's
get on with it what if a sheik asked me
to go over to saudi arabia do you think
i should do it i've had it what's the
price
i once got offered legitimately 50 000
they were gonna wire it beforehand
no to fly over the sex with the sheik
yeah but they'll never let you leave
they're like they can [ __ ] hold you a
prisoner those guys are crazy
they have like slaves in saudi arabia
they wouldn't know if i was missing
someone would be like oh she went to go
see a sheik and now she's missing yeah
but who's going to
who's going to go in there and take you
back i have an israeli boyfriend
sorry um he's like the zohan zoan ain't
getting your ass for out of [ __ ]
saudi arabia
oh okay maybe i won't go you'll be in a
[ __ ] cage dude
oh my god that's so extreme i'm just
saying dude these
these sheiks and these people in dubai
and saudi arabia
they bring girls over and they literally
turn them into sex slaves
that sucks like it really does not being
serious like i don't want people to get
laughing that's so crazy yeah it does
suck
like no that would seriously suck so bad
so bad
all right anyway that was maybe i
appreciate that
oh you got here this was fun you got
backlash for your last mook bang you
made because some homeless person asked
for food
oh my god and you fight you drove off
which is awesome trafficking and sex
slaves this is exactly we were almost
sex trafficked and everyone's like wow
you wouldn't give them food
sex traffic there was one solitary
person asking for food
there was two men in the back seat and a
man next to her she's in a car
she says i'm from hawaii but i have
money i'll pay you back but can you give
us food
in a car next to us doesn't say she's a
fan or anything she was just like
and then as soon as i said can you wait
till we're eating because i'm trying to
get out of the situation she goes to
back up her car to back us in
there's two guys on either side there's
a guy in the front and then a guy in the
back so there's two guys total in her
she's like oh i'm from hawaii 20 minutes
prior another guy on camera is like hey
i'm from hawaii you want to want a
boyfriend i want to hang out with me
and it was just all really sus and then
she said she's from town doesn't have
money how did you get here [ __ ]
second of all she's like oh can you give
us some food i'm not broke but i'll pay
you back
okay what okay can i stop you i feel
like you're embellishing
based on this video i'm embellishing
what okay let's watch the video okay
you guys are eating some [ __ ] i
don't love that
um
she's in that car she's not even a
drifter she's in a car she is
well we don't really have any cash or
anything i'm putting my seat up because
i'm nervous
second drive away um okay can we finish
eating
so much but what do we do can you
i find it interesting that you didn't
remove this part why'd you leave it in
because later on we talked about it
first okay don't ever roll it down here
no you know what even if you're a fan i
will never hold down my window again
don't roll down your window for anyone
if you're uncomfortable
don't give someone food the minute you
reach out an arm is a minute they can
grab you they can kidnap you
i got i didn't connect i got held ransom
at mexico true story i never talked
about this for this very reason
there was a resort opening it you have
way too many stories you got held ransom
in mexico
i swear tell me everything but i don't
like to give people ideas because this
is what so [ __ ] don't go to mexico
i'm not i'm done going to mexico
never yeah i'll never but i was posting
for this resort and you know what it's a
chain hotel it was a big chain
they invited you there yeah nobody was
there right someone [ __ ] ransomed
your ass
what city were you in we were in like
next to right next to the cabo one
is it called nakabo cosmo cosmo
cosmo is it i don't know it's like a big
one it's like one where they have
reported vallarta
not puerto vallarta but it's one with
the c so it might have been cosmo
okay whatever you were in mexico no
maybe it was cobble
anyway okay it's in cabo and it was and
we were going to the van from the hotel
that the hotel was going to provide us
back to the airport
so i'm posting for them like hey we'll
give you like a free stay like come post
for us so i'm posting right
and so obviously people are seeing like
my instagram and they saw that i just
bought a lamborghini like all this stuff
so they're seeing like all this stuff
and it was so weird nobody else was at
this resort nobody there was
construction going on
the food was like frozen pizza do you
think they set you up
frozen pizza literally frozen pizza and
was it good huh was the pizza good no it
was all horrible it was really really
bad
and i don't really like to share because
i just don't like to give like the
details of it because it's honestly it
was honestly the most like the scariest
thing in my life but
we were held at gunpoint to give money
they needed us to get money out and i
couldn't get the transfer they wanted
like
they wanted like a hundred thousand
dollars and i couldn't do it and then
they wanted me to get out of the atm
first of all and i was like okay there's
no way obviously not
i'm not gonna get that though i get
twenty thousand on the atm i have to
physically go inside and get the money
so we ended up wiring them money like it
was so scary they literally like left us
on a ditch they had like literally a gun
to my head like i
i just don't really like like i
literally i can't believe you've never
talked about you never talked about this
i don't like giving people ideas i don't
like like
i'm very paranoid for this reason and
any time you watch my mukbang you'll see
people are like she's super paranoid
there's
clips of me like jutting out when i see
anyone come out of their car towards my
car i'll jut out
whatever even if it's not for me i'm
ultra ultra paranoid because of this
happening and this happened another time
i got held
at gunpoint in my house and it was the
same thing where
it like they did i'm like take whatever
take whatever and they were like no you
have to wire me money so there's two
times that i was held
what is that for ransom i don't know
what that is but it was to robbery
so my dad too my dad has money and
people know this like he sold his
company for a [ __ ] ton of money really
your dad's rich
so my dad has money and they were like
you so
the same thing had happened to me when i
was younger like when i lived with him
like 19
and it's happened so many times and i
was in a pink girls rice and yes it's
flashy whatever say what you want it's
like oh you're an expensive car what do
you expect people are gonna and it's
true but
that's such a target people obviously
obviously know i have money this is a
girl and i think whatever
there's so many things that the moment i
know the moment you put yourself in a
vulnerable situation one time me
extending my [ __ ] hand when i worked
at hooters on hollywood boulevard
was the cause of [ __ ] someone raping
me on hollywood boulevard and the cops
didn't do [ __ ] about it
like it's because you know why i gave
someone i extended someone money because
i thought that was the thing to do
don't [ __ ] do that thing and don't
ever listen to people being like oh like
you should have done this what a [ __ ]
like
[ __ ] you like i'm a female my my mom 60
in the back my sister's right in this
seat
the only reason i put my window down is
i felt a little safer with my mom and
sister in the car if it was just me by
myself i would have like
booked it out of there and honestly i
should have and as soon as i saw her
backing up and backing in
you'll see i kind of swerved out to kind
of get out because she was backing us in
that [ __ ] i was that's the that's just
[ __ ] this is
this for my birthday this year i gave 32
000 away 10 000 to my followers like i
i am like the least selfless person but
i'm i'm definitely you come up to my car
like [ __ ] you
wait can i ask you about this so do you
think they set you up when you went to
that resort to rob you
i don't know if they set me up or
someone just saw that i was posting a
lot and they knew where i was
so they're like oh this girl has money
like i don't know
mexico is really unsafe right now i
would not encourage anybody to go there
i'll never go back to mexico yeah me and
eva used to go there all the time and we
had really sketchy experiences and we
stopped going
yeah where did you guys go we've been
all over the place
my parents lived there for like five
years and back then it was like much
safer and i feel like since the rise of
the cartel there
things have just become more lawless and
what happened with you guys was sketchy
well i was just super paranoid like we
would go to resorts and i felt like
people were following us
and like because i would post on social
media like you said and be like oh [ __ ]
you know people are gonna
because people get people get kidnapped
there all the time yeah
um where my parents were living they
there was like a [ __ ] straight up
gang war with grenades and like
automatic rifles there was like grenade
explosions and holes in the wall
everywhere my parents bounced
after that happened and like even at the
airport like i brought my drone because
i was gonna vlog
and they [ __ ] they go you cannot
enter mexico unless you pay me sales tax
on this drone
yeah and he was like on some crazy
[ __ ]
thing telling me that my drone costs
three times more than it did
and was trying to charge me a thousand
dollars did you pay it i had to
yeah i got arrested for bringing my
camera i was blogging it was insane and
they arrested me and then they told me
the same thing they're like you have to
pay us money
if you want to get it it was just a
straight up he just pocketed that money
for sure
he's like it's the law i was like show
me the law i looked up at like the
the mexican laws for coming i was like
there's no [ __ ] law
that says this he's like dude you gotta
go you have to leave or pay me
i was like all right [ __ ] i'm never
coming back to your [ __ ] exactly and you
should be paranoid for that reason and
i'm so [ __ ] tired of people like
judging people for
feeling uncomfortable like anytime you
feel uncomfortable don't [ __ ] do that
actually i shouldn't call it a [ __ ]
country because i
love mexico and mexican people and the
culture and the food and everything it's
so vibrant beautiful and i love being
there
it's just a shame that it's uh become
so corrupt and lawless and it's just
it's tough it's so scary it's so so
scary
but that that's crazy so he so you were
outside the resort and then he
we're going back to the the um the
what's the
airport airport oh you're right you were
leaving
and you grabbed the taxi no we took the
van from the hotel
and that's the guy who kidnapped you oh
they must have been on on it
i think so because they didn't help us
the whole time we were there like um
another incident did you report it to
the police or anything
um when we got back we reported it
because it's a chain hotel and we
reported it to the chain hotel and
literally nobody cared like no one said
anything
did you tell the social media person who
told you to come there
you never responded huh the resort is
still there too you could probably sue
them because they're
probably international big company i
know it was so scary honestly like it
just felt
like even now talking about i literally
still feel like like so what happened in
the car you got in the car
the guy's driving when did you know
there's something wrong
almost immediately he's like do you guys
have cash on you and we're like
no and then he's like well
you need to go and take out a hundred
dollars from each other oh immediately
he was like
yeah and then we saw we were going off
the path like because where we were it
wasn't
it's like los cabos or something so i
stayed there before at this place called
resort at pedro so it's like in that
area
but this was like a little bit off from
that you know what i mean and it was a
resort and so he went off like the
beaten path like you know and i was just
like [ __ ]
and it just felt bad right away and i
was like i i can't get thousand dollars
out of atm and then he
asked me to take ten thousand i gotta go
inside to get that and he wouldn't let
me go get it
so we did a wire you went in the bank
did a wire
i didn't go in i did it for my phone
really you can do that
yeah and he got it immediately
well he got it and then he took my id
and he took
like i think i had like
i don't know if i had to check i took
everything like he had all my cards and
stuff like that he had all my address
like everything so i don't like talking
about this honestly like
i got phone calls after harassing me
being like
um we're gonna like cut your head off
like all this crazy [ __ ] for more money
what and so it's just like
i only talked about it because i know
people like oh trisha trolls and all
stuff that's like i like i don't like
talking about it but like
that's the reason i'm like so paranoid
and like earlier this year someone came
into my house like while i was showering
and like
it was like a very similar situation it
was very eerie it wasn't it didn't have
to do with the stalker or whatever it
was like
a very similar situation and it scared
the [ __ ] out of me like you've been in a
lot of scary situations i've never been
anxious
the person literally broke into scare me
because he didn't take anything and it
was
so terrifying and like um like any time
i feel like uncomfortable in any
situation i just like leave now
it's like and i should have because
every single time like when i've like
i was raped twice on hollywood boulevard
and it was both times when i was giving
someone something i put my hand out
and that's when they like were able to
like
um i don't think you should ever give
anything out homeless people they'll use
kids as a tactic i've had that happen
where someone literally used a child
and the child was like i need money and
then that's when they came out from
behind at my gate at hollywood and
highland
before there was like the condos there
was a burger king and it happened
right in the back the back lot of that
and there was a kid there and like he
wanted the money
and then that's when the guys came out
and like mugged me raped me all that
[ __ ] i was just like
it's crazy and the fact that people like
are even putting that out there are
shame on them like press hilton on
tick-tock being like oh wow you should
have given them
like giving them food like [ __ ] off like
seriously [ __ ] off like it's so [ __ ]
annoying that that's like the
like that's what people are putting out
there like don't ever roll down your
windows don't ever give people [ __ ]
homeless people included homeless people
will are [ __ ] crazy too like i'm
sorry you're in that situation but i'm
not going to put my like
money i just give money to a food bank
you don't have to give people you know
exactly
i gave money to cover to relief doctors
without borders like trans equality like
for people to take trans people off the
street i donate
i do that you know it's just it's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] up
it pisses me off to know and i left that
in because afterwards i said like
no i'm not doing that like what the [ __ ]
like i i wouldn't leave it in if i
thought it looked bad like i would have
edited it out but i was like and i'm
so glad it blew up because i want more
people to know that like not to say
we're being self trafficked we're i
think we're past that age but that's
exactly what happens people leave a
little flyer out there people
say oh like an injury you know try to
run into your cars like all this
[ __ ]
if you if you if someone runs into your
car trying to act like you hit them go
to the police like just
call the police and be like this person
says i hit him i didn't but i'm gonna
drive because i don't feel comfortable
getting out because it happens at night
i had a guy literally run into my car
and like flip over
and i called the cops and it's just like
it's just there's so much sketchy [ __ ]
when you're a girl
i think when you're out and you're
driving around in a car like that you
attract all those people who are trying
to get a piece of you
moses sees it when we're eating in the
car like literally people will be like
roll down your window like just
you know or come up to the car knock on
it i don't want a rolls royce anymore
it sounds scary in that [ __ ] car dude
it is the world is scary in that car
scary just i drive it here
i'm getting a prius bro i'm [ __ ] i'm
getting a prius for my next car
well that's why i got the bentley
because i wanted to ask like my every
day that's your broke ass
basic car ben leaves tonight an
expensive car too you know
well we're gonna get like a jeep or
something i think get a prius please
okay no but anyways i don't know that's
like a toyota corolla or some [ __ ] dude
see no one will bother you no one will
bother you in that car
oh how long we've been going dan
wrap it up
all right let's do the read hey
guys it's adam and
oh together adam and eve hey guys the
best thing about staying home is playing
at home
doing so without you such a pro it's
awesome
with uh 50 off with the code h3 and you
know what
that's insanely good you get 50 off plus
free shipping
but here's something even my code won't
do that only the h3 code this is true
i don't know why my code doesn't do this
you also get
10 free movies six gifts one for him one
for her
couples yeah what if i just buy like a
five dollar item
there's no five dollar item but they
have
click eaters i don't know if you can say
that eater they have a [ __ ] eater that
is insane that's how i
orgasm today and what is it it literally
does not it feels like it's head on you
it's so
crazy it's like so lifelike um i wish i
knew the name i'm so sorry but
it is on if you go to clip simulators
you'll see it it's like a little pink
thing with a little mouth on it it's
amazing holy [ __ ] um they have g-spot
hitters so that's how you're gonna do
the squirt
and can i milk my prostate with anything
there they do have those penises that
that they can expand what if i don't
want to put a penis in my ass but i want
to milk my prostate do they have
something for that
yeah they have those suction cups but
it's for your penis suction cup it
suctions you out
i think it's called clona willy it's on
eve.com clone and willie
let's go that's really a product on
there it's really good dude you are like
you know their inventory i love it they
also have holiday lingerie right now we
had a
reindeer g string for uh my boyfriend
and he can put your penis in it i also
award you what you were you got a g
string yeah you want to see the ring i
wore it i can't imagine that looks very
good on your mouse it's no offense
moses looks so hot um do you want me to
show you the range
string or do you have time i don't know
show me the of you or of him
which one would you rather see i don't
know either of them
yeah but you could show me yeah i'll
show you all right nevermind
um let me see i want to go i'll give it
the review of that
you can't show it on i feel like show me
you can't show them but i'll tell them
what i'm saying
because it's crap because it's a graphic
bare ass adamav.com
h3 okay for a 50 off code h3 plus free
shipping if you're in the u.s and canada
all right dude i mean what handles the
size
adam and eve has got toys for everybody
it's uh
what can what can you say about adam and
eve how support
support the show adam
here let me see okay there it is oh my
god this is so this is somebody okay
okay this is like weird ignore my face
here's just the g string
it's for your penis but i wore it too oh
you put your penis in it that's pretty
funny and then the pasties are also from
adam neither edible reindeer pasties
adamandeve.com this i put this on
instagram and youtube so it's fine
um and edible pasties so it's like a
soft it's like a you put your peanuts
it's like a what do you call it it's
like a
it's like a holster for your penis in
the fifth in the face of a reindeer yeah
so check that out adam.com use code h3
it's our only sponsor right now so
please
we're desperate please support the show
if you care about us
and um yeah pleasure yourself this
holiday season if you order now you'll
get it before christmas it comes in a
discreet packaging
it does not say anime it doesn't say sex
toys it comes in a brown package from
north carolina so it could be discreet
so yeah adamandeve.com use code h3 at
checkout thank you guys
you know what i was thinking we just
keep talking and then if you're
available on wednesday
we can do this as a separate episode
second episode do
the math yeah i mean yeah but you have a
set up now well we'll just leave it and
then refrigerate what we can
are you sure yeah it'll be awesome
because i want people to watch that what
do you think about that idea dan
it's up to you whatever you guys want
are you available on wednesday yeah
great
are you sure i feel bad everyone's here
yes no it's great it's fun
people will be happy they get two
episodes this week
okay
i never stopped recording oh keep on
going do the ad reader know how to read
right now we'll do it
okay okay so anyways we have more to
talk about though i mean that's kind of
like whatever i have a lot oh well let
me finish that video because i want to
see
how you react move the car
yeah let's go oh why is everybody
from white that is a good question why
are all these people from hawaii because
20 minutes prior you hear a guy i left
that whole no but i feel like i've heard
people say that to me before too it's
like i'm from hawaii i don't have change
for the bus
can you give me yeah i think so i think
i hear from hawaii then yeah well she's
leaving
everybody in if you guys are so worried
how come you're still munching on
burgers
it's like one of those things where it's
just like i mean because here's the
thing like
nine chances out of ten like the person
maybe wasn't gonna like harm us so i was
like but it was
right away i'm just like we gotta get
out of here so it was just like an
awkward thing in general but we do
we do leave quick let me watch this i
think she's just did you tell her no
i didn't she's not going to block you in
we might have to just like leave yeah
that's okay
i got my like cheese okay can you hold
it i wish i could eat like you guys i
wish i just
cheese i would be such a like i mean i
just wish i could like mook bang with
you guys all day
i know but it's really unhealthy because
i have a big eating disorder so i just
don't eat for the next couple days like
it's bad like
you like a few days without eating yeah
i skip meals i have a binge eating
disorder excuse me don't
ever skip
okay so this is enough this is a perfect
example so this was a mukbang where you
can see where oh are you and
are you like trying to look black it's
just a wig oh my god
you look like you're trying to look oh
my god bro you saw that tick tock where
the dad
hold on do you is that in the dock where
the dad comes in and he goes yo is this
chick black
oh there's a girl have you seen that no
i'll show you yeah
yeah show me okay so soon she probably
loved that
[Music]
what is this what happened holy [ __ ]
you're panicking
[Music]
are you in the mm-hmm what the [ __ ] was
that yeah
my one friend texted me like what the
[ __ ] happened because like literally
within seconds like i'm like
you were quick exactly so like wait what
happened
so there was a i was in a i was
basically in somebody's driveway and
someone parks behind me like
but blocks me in you know sort of thing
not like they're parking behind me but i
was basically in the red by someone's
driveway so they're like gonna like
block me in again to not move and so
immediately i see i see the car i'm like
watching it and all of a sudden two guys
one enters out of the driver's side one
of the passengers and they come on
either side of my car
so that's when i'm like oh [ __ ] i don't
want to hit this person and that other
car was coming
and literally like this guy that does a
drama channel was like what the [ __ ]
happened like
i this happens all this time this
happens so much but um on the
african-american note did you see that
this girl might
look alike
[Music]
okay so on the black fishing thing i
told you i did twenty three of these
black fish is that what you said that i
was trying to blackfish people i didn't
ever the term blackfish
okay well that's the thing people what's
blackfishing is like when you they say
you're trying to look
black okay oh are you black do you
blackfish people say that but because i
like tan and stuff but here's the thing
i actually have moroccan in me i told
you this that doesn't make you black you
said you have like three percent
okay moroccan i think he's like well
aren't moroccans mostly like
yeah they're american they're african
yeah but they're arabs they're not
they're not african you're one of us
girl i know
but but wait wait wait you're not
hearing yourself
you're that doesn't make you black that
makes you aries or rockings that are
are dark okay i'm not black fishing that
is in my dna i don't want to make that a
big thing because then people okay wait
watch this watch this watch this
watch this clip if you haven't seen this
you're going to love it i know i'm not
african-american but i'm just saying
you're a black fish no but sometimes i
hit hands
watch this come here
you haven't seen this no it's the best
thing ever can you say that again
you're recording this is this girl
black or white oh my god
why so aggressive watch this black mom
says she's white
yeah she's black girl
she's black we gotta sound like that
girl she's black
oh and he says i'm like howard's
strength oh wow what a couple minutes i
know and you're blocked
what a compliment you don't like people
you don't like talking about hearthstone
because is it because
i don't care i talk about how it's
certain i'm
this is one of the bullsh things that
you're always obsessed about that's so
annoying
you go you don't even talk about her
start i say i have no problem talking
about how trying like how's it
like every time i gotta [ __ ] answer
this for me to do be on his show full
time but i had to leave this podcast
yeah what would happen if i was elected
the president of the united states
overnight
howard stern loves me i believe what he
said was you would be pretty if you
weren't so
chubby how did you know that did you
know that
because you've said it like 20 times to
me america's got talent i think he
thought i was hot
so this so this family thinks you're
black you've got the black hair
you're black fishing just admit you're
black vegetables
you're arab you have arab roots you're
not african-american you're a black fish
what and then what's your name on
tick-tock tricia blackfish
just like fish um interesting well you
know here's the thing honestly i should
do another dna test because i really do
think i probably have some
african-american me and honestly
i'd be proud i'd be honored with that
why would it change why would it change
i feel like i just never knew because my
whole life and i'm not
why if you did a dna test the second
time would it change the origin
because i did a 23 me and then i did
like an ancestry one and it was told
they were they were different
i think they just described the regions
differently
so oh we should do that on together well
mine's so boring it's 99.3 percent
ashkenazi jewel congrats thank you
you're like a whole
jew i'm gonna hold the whole [ __ ]
locker wow
um those are good the first time i'm
having them today with the latkes um
no but i really do think so my whole
life people have always asked me if i
was like
african-american oh here's one
yeah yeah i brought it for you guys i
was in a better mood once i came
do you want to uh i want one you want me
to show me no mother's looking mad at me
i always wanna show you what's wrong
because i'm always so
impressed wait you'll get mad if she
shows me the score game
yeah okay oh really but it's not only
fans
i showed ryland she didn't care
would you be mad at me if i went and
watched your squirting videos
interesting so i can't what if he pays
me five dollars right now
no i don't want your sister in short
i guess you masturbating oh god please
no
if that's your thing no is that your
thing
yeah i love showing people my squirting
i'm so proud of it okay
so so so moses doesn't want me to see
the school you're technically not fam
i mean you're not blood related we're
family he's my brother-in-law
yeah okay
i won't would you want to describe it to
me why are you so proud about it so
proud because it hit the record button
so it stopped recording and i was so
proud of it dude i don't think i can
handle seeing you scroll
to be honest with you we have to control
the delicate balance of the show once i
see your ass squirting
then i think that might be the only
thing i see when i see you which isn't
good
okay and not in a sexual way i mean look
at that oh wait
like damn [ __ ] what the [ __ ] kind of
way
can i just say for the record i
go ahead people think i'm like serious
when i'm like
they think i flirt with you i like in no
way do i find you attractive or want to
have sex with you like i just want to
make that very very clear
like uh-huh i hate that people think
that i'm like that's clearly a joke well
stop hitting on me every time okay if
you were like
because we're supposed to be friends if
you look like noah beck i wouldn't be
saying that to you you know what i'm
saying like it's obvious
because i'm so disgusting then it's an
obvious joke yes
thank you good
okay because people like i respect his
marriage i'm like ew i wouldn't
no i'd rather have sex with traitor
shredder you rather [ __ ] my dog
that's not better that's weird just
weirder you'd rather [ __ ]
i would rather [ __ ] a dog you think
shredder could penetrate you oh my god
oh my god ew oh my god
why did you say my dog wasn't there a
better example
because i would literally i'm that bad
with anybody i'm that bad
i mean i don't know but i just i like
it's not my thing
would you [ __ ] a dog no i know well you
said you would i don't know i'm just
asking questions
you opened that on me i feel like people
are like wow you're so disrespectful to
their marriage i
like be married forever like i couldn't
care less you don't care if we get
divorced
are you cause you keep bringing that up
are you guys getting a divorce no you
said i wouldn't say you brought it up
you said i wouldn't
care if you guys okay whatever here
here's a video i wouldn't care if you
got a divorce do whatever you want
who cares stupid let's watch this okay
you definitely want to [ __ ] me though
it's obvious to everybody no because
it's
that's the thing when someone's so
unattractive you make that joke like the
first time i met you wow that's so nice
you go
wow i want to [ __ ] you you're just such
an ugly [ __ ] feel better like when i
first met you guys
you're 10 you're a 10 because you were
constantly so let me get this straight
you flirt with ugly people of course to
make them feel better
then you also say you but then you say i
[ __ ] everybody
who's interested in me um so what you're
saying is i flirt with every ugly person
and if they reciprocated i [ __ ] them
that doesn't make it that's either
insane or doesn't make any sense and
frankly i could
i could take it either way with you oh
take what either way
you being insane or not making sense
i can't wait for dr drew to come back on
because he would not approve of you
calling me insane yeah well [ __ ]
dr drew can
give us a personality test to figure it
out which is next week
is he just gonna be on zoom he's not
coming here yeah oh
i like having people here physically i
wish we could too but dr drew's out
there to live in his life in a way get
tested the day before
he's not about it how could we do it
could we put a mask on him and just
he's probably not even into it he's busy
no he's busy he's busy
he said he wanted to come in yeah he's
busy you're just saying that
okay ready doctor's house so you made
fun of oh really would you [ __ ] doctor
joe if i was single
how do i know you're not just saying
that and giving him a pity
would you rather [ __ ] shredder or dr
drew
okay just making sure okay what about
lassie or doctor joe
lassie's doctor i don't want to [ __ ] a
dog i don't want to [ __ ] mr ed
or dr joe well probably mr ride has a
bigger penis
that's what i'm saying he definitely
does
all right oh my god wait so i went home
and did all my videos for no reason
we're not even doing this [ __ ] beauty
hack thing today
well that's sometimes the cookie
crumbles the way cookie crumbles
no but everybody gets a double episode
because yes
last month we only did three so this
week we're getting a double episode
because it's christmas
so stressed about freaking can i show
you this video people
you know what i mean it's like oh i was
so stressed let's just watch let's just
try
it while i watch it yeah
yeah it's crazy i ate a whole [ __ ] i ate
a whole bag dude
it's hanukkah
nice job baby thank you sorry
um so i have some ray i had this viral
video
pretty funny but hey let's watch it you
did a reaction to
it here we go
girl you are not doing this please tell
me this isn't
i real we're awfully waiting for a photo
i'm all for doing these things in public
but like waiting 10 seconds to say hi
people watch awkwardly dance making so
much money give me
i don't know might not have been the
move here okay i have a i have a counter
argument
it's called cam you can vowed that jelly
holy [ __ ]
i don't eat pretty is that what it's
like when she's on her that's you on her
period
sorry i'm ready that was a lot
to see that i don't eat pretty i was as
bad as watching you squirt
you didn't see it come
squirt.com um okay what what's your
connor
she's super famous she probably gets
recognized a lot so she's like
she's like hold the [ __ ] on i gotta
do my dumb ass she's not
what's more like putting you know years
of his life into training for like
benjamin button she probably gets
stopped all the time
yeah so take a picture but i'm just
saying she has [ __ ] to do
there's probably someone else who's like
take the photo with me and she's like
okay cool take a photo of me okay cool
and then
go [ __ ] somewhere else into your
mansion that you'd like to do this don't
do it you hate me
i don't hate her at all i don't are you
mad that she's more famous you know what
i don't like i don't like their i don't
like these tick tock attitudes i don't
know what it is about tick tockers
i saw her on a podcast and she's like
i'm the first person to be like this
popular on social media i'm like girl
she said that yeah i was like she goes
there was there's no one to talk about
this because this is like
the first time like we're blowing up
like this and i was like it was on the
zane and he's popcast if you guys want
to go watch it if you want to believe me
because she literally was just like
just so full of herself and i was just
like oh like i hate these people because
it's
this specifically okay you could say i'm
a shitty person or whatever but if you
ask me to take a photo
you best even if i'm in the middle of
you which i think is kind of rude i
still will put down my burger
and i still will be like okay yeah it's
like i've never said the only time i
said wait is if i'm like
crying hysterically and like one time my
like my oh guy was dating died and
that's and this person came up and i
have a picture and i was just like uh
like can you just hold on like literally
one minute so i can like wipe my face
and i still took a picture with that
person
your boyfriend died oh yeah in 2009
well i wasn't dating him at the time but
we had but i was staying at his house
when he died
oh [ __ ] anyways that's a lot it's heavy
you've been through a lot damn girl you
were [ __ ] been through
everything um what haven't you been
through a lot i mean there's a lot i
haven't been through there's so much
stuff i hear that's like
horrifying to me like you've never met
an arab until today um i think i did
date a muslim at one point
oh yeah so you lied about not ever but i
couldn't interview him
okay it was just you know so anyway you
know what really surprised me about this
tick tock more than anything
she does this without any music all in
one take like what the [ __ ] she might
have earphones in
like she has earbuds yeah but like she
does it in one take
oh my god so cringe eat it up take it
down
wrap the head around it raise the roof
look at this girl like what the [ __ ] is
happening
he looks so stupid so stupid like
i'm more interested in just the candid
like
aspect of her recording a tick-tock
dance than like her rudely telling
people to wait
but she's like at that late it's she was
really nice about it she wasn't like
[ __ ]
do you know who i am of course not but
how like
take a p you don't have to wait this is
my favorite move this one
i'll eat you up whenever you tell me i'm
pretty i can do this dancing
okay should we tick-tock this
i'll eat you up
oh you look good you look skinny today
thanks not after that brittle
anyway i didn't have i didn't really
have a problem with it no
i thought people are giving hard on her
i don't think they're being hard on her
because
she's really not humble i think people
just need to literally just be humble
like jesus well i don't know anything
about her like i just watched on this
podcast and just rubbing me on because i
thought she was like a sweet one
but she would be acting like she's just
like the first person to ever get a
movie
role she's like yeah i got this movie
role i'm an actress i've been acting my
whole life it's like
[ __ ] is like chill she's like it's just
it's just too much and
and here's the thing do i really care if
she's like no but like hey it's a viral
video i commented on it i'm just trying
to get out there too you know yeah no
why these people that go to be oh my god
the people who go to boa are the
cringiest like james charles dixie
bow a steakhouse they go there every
night to get paparazzi it's not open
anymore but they
they go there to get paparazzi and then
they ask act like they don't want to
answer questions like okay i gotta go i
gotta go into boa which is like it's
known to be a paparazzi place so you go
there to get paparazzi and it's so
cringy
i should start doing that you think
paparazzi will care about me they
wouldn't even [ __ ]
recognize me i'd walk all slow
you're interesting because you don't go
out you're someone i you know i think
they would ask me
you think they recognize me i don't
because like i used to go out with post
malone and they he
i would there's a bunch of pictures of
me just standing in the background
of his photos catfish by post malone say
what i got catfish by post malone
what does that mean like i didn't know
who post malone was for the longest time
somebody catfished you and i was like oh
this guy with tattoos into me and you
know he's like a little chubby so i
thought i was like had fish by post
malone when was this
um tell me it was at least five years
like a year ago
oh wow wait i'm sorry but just rewind
time
rewind ah because i mean i hate to bring
this up but you were giving moses [ __ ]
for getting catfished by a famous person
and you literally got catfished by post
malone a year ago
so what the [ __ ] he told me he was
supposed to alone he's like oh you
actually thought it was postponed
i didn't know who was like i'm a rapper
here's my music and he would send me did
you send a video of you squirting
uh i didn't squirt back then no not back
then but
we've done a long one it was after my it
was after i was on here i think on on
the first time i was on h3
so did you send him like news or
something how far did the relationship
go
um i we were like
gonna meet up we like i literally was
like at a restaurant multiple times to
meet up and
he never showed up oh he just flaked
well you know he was probably just
sitting there watching you
dude you got catfished multiple times by
post malone and you're [ __ ]
criticizing moses
sorry girl and he told me like yeah but
this is my song and i i didn't know who
he was i was like oh that makes sense
he's like a rapper and he's like you
know what i mean like i didn't know so i
didn't seem like a famous person like
talking to me so how did you find out he
was not real
um oh cause i ca it was after so i came
on the podcast
and i was like yeah those are my friends
so i googled you guys together and i saw
that he was on your podcast
and i was like okay well maybe this is
like legit or something like that
and the reason i kind of found out that
it like wasn't him
it's cause he asked me to like venmo him
and i didn't have memo and then he asked
you to venmo him god
talk about gullible how much did he ask
for i didn't have emma at the time
um he needed he wanted he wanted to fly
here but like his credit cards had just
gotten stolen so they can use about can
you just like bend over bro
you were literally getting catfished by
like some nigerian prince
no i talked to him on the phone like
he's he's like yo what up
like i don't know what possible sounds
like but that's
but he had me i mean you know because he
didn't look like a famous person to me
and he kind of looked like me and he's
like everyone said we look alike and i
was like oh okay
and so i was like maybe this makes sense
of why you collect post malone oh yeah
people tell me like
him and samuel jackson are like the two
and matthew lillard you look like samuel
jackson yeah matthew lillard stop stop
people tell you you look like an old
black man when i was younger i swear i
swear when i was younger
people made fun of me because they told
me i looked like samuel jackson
there was a movie where he moved into
suburbia from who told you you look like
samuel jackson
kids in my school they literally made
fun of me what is that movie oh he moves
into a neighborhood
and he like harasses the neighbors i
forgot what it's called but like
everyone's like
they would call me his name in that
movie and it was like popular at the
time for some reason i still can't
remember it but
um yeah it's odd so i used to like
memorize pulp fiction so i could like
more evidence that you're black fishing
okay i didn't even tan back we should
title this episode
trisha admits to black fishing
can i wait can i say this might be might
get me canceled again whatever but like
why is it so wrong to want to look like
it's not blackface blackface is mocking
people right but like i
love a darker complexion like why is it
so
i don't think there's anything wrong
with dark way that i was wearing like i
like their hairstyles better like
i get the box braids i get stuff like
that but like stuff that like you said
in that
the video i showed you with the curly
hair i was like are you black fishing
it's like okay maybe that's like a style
that like african-american women will
wear but like
i and truly correct me if i'm wrong but
like why why is it bad like if i want to
look like like beyonce if i see like an
outfit or her hairstyle like why
can't i look like that i think there's
nothing wrong with wanting to look like
her
just don't try to like make your skin
dark like her like tanning you think so
tan no tanning is fine but like but
that's making your skin but there's like
no yeah no tanning is fine but like if
you're trying to make yourself look bad
black it's just like i hate the way it
looks pale like you can see like
i'm tannering my face in this and it's
like there's no there's nothing wrong
with any of that it's just a matter of
how far do you take it
yeah i mean i'm not trying to say i'm
african-american or
anything like that i was just like what
does that mean though when i was a kid
people told me i like samuel jackson and
i wasn't tanning
it's just like making sure they weren't
[ __ ] with you no like they're and i
you know i was okay with it i thought he
was very handsome
and i will strike down upon thee with
great vengeance
moses was not [ __ ] samuel jackson what
if
i was samuel jackson
you and anybody my son oh thank you so
if my soul was yeah
if you were samuel jackson moses would
[ __ ] him in that case
yeah because it's my being my essence so
anyway
watch this addiction to tanning and i
know that sounds really fun
trisha i'm not trying to start oh no
wait wait wait wait no give me anxiety
stop watch watch watch an impulsive like
logan paul's
um podcast where you were talking about
how it was [ __ ] and you did it for
literally views i will show you the clip
oh yeah
you were on a show right a show like my
strange addiction
for like for tanning oh yeah but that
was [ __ ] like i wasn't related
to anything okay okay so everything i'm
about to say is completely irrelevant
yeah well i mean i've been addicted but
definitely not tanning i just did it
on the show because it was a canoe and
like we're looking for people with
addictions and i was like all right
this you um
so which is it okay well i mean i can
explain it why do you lie about [ __ ]
it wasn't lying that was a whole
disassociation so when as soon as i got
on
on impulsive from the beginning i
realized like they were really like
i don't use the word like aggressive but
you could just tell right away they were
just not about me like they were in
defense of everyone david dobrik like
jason like everything that i was going
through that year because this was
months after my breakup like a couple
months
they set it up a game called like hate
like
basically saying like let's hate on
these youtubers and the minute they're
like let's hear like your biggest
critiques of these people so i went off
but then they turn it around on me
and was like wow maybe like maybe you
have some issues like why are you so
mad at david and like all of a sudden it
was basically like they didn't do
anything wrong like it was that and so
right away i was like on the defense so
that whole time that whole interview
just like america's that talent just
like stuff where it's like i literally
i it wasn't true what you're saying
you're just well yeah because oh my god
you did have an addiction to tanning of
course okay good i felt fat tanning made
me feel skinny like of course i did
but the problem was also that show was
really traumatic because they tried to
test me for skin cancer on the show and
i actually
yeah and i walked off the show if you
watched my show wait did you love it
um prior to that i had skin cancer
removed so i didn't want to get tested
because i thought they were trying to
get me set up to make me look like i'm
an idiot because i continued tanning
after i had uh
cancer in my my backside and so i didn't
want
i don't know about this either because i
just don't like people like like this
well this happened and you continued to
tan and you did this so this is a lot
like i just hate this [ __ ] because i
i don't mind explaining myself it's just
like i don't always want to explain
myself because i'm like she always has
explained herself whatever but
um with stuff like the really personal
like
the tanning addiction like it's easier
for me to be like it was a joke i just
want like okay america's that town this
is a perfect example it's a little like
more lighthearted
i got buzzed off america's got talent
and so my
instinct kicked in not instinct but like
i guess i guess called disassociation i
don't know
that word i'm not really so sure about
but they all started making fun of me
like i realized i was being set up
because america's got talent which this
is something to talk about too they do
this notoriously to people they set up
another girl that was a pink
impersonator
anyways um they set me up to fail
basically they told me to do the star
spangled banner when i get there they're
like oh no you can do the star-spangled
banner it's copyright just make
something up on the spot
what they put me out there of music and
i they didn't tell me they were playing
music so all of a sudden there's a beat
and they're like
bath talk so anyways i was set up for
failure from so you were
you were meant to be the punching bag
yes but you didn't know that at all i
didn't because at the time i was 21 or
something
did you think that talking fast was a
talent that would get you through to the
end
um no it wasn't really necessarily that
they just kind of hyped me up like this
is so
cool like they're gonna love it and at
21 i wasn't like a troll or anything yet
so to me i'm like oh yeah i like that
they got you good now if i go on a show
i realize like i'm
the punching make me and i'm fine with
it now i think being older and like
realizing that's what i am it's okay
but um i think at the time i really did
think like
oh maybe can we watch that club okay
here can i tell you i was on ellen for
and they they hyped me up ellen was like
this is awesome
yeah for sure and then i was on a carl's
jr commercial for fast talking so like
you think it was good unless you paid
for a college junior commercial i mean i
wasn't much it was like a talent show
thing the carl's jr talent show
well it was a commercial but anyways but
bottom line is i was doing stuff with my
fast talking so i thought
i did guinness world records you know
okay you yeah yeah so in my head i was
like oh this is just another show
i was on jay leno for fast talking like
i was oh my goodness so
i was like oh this is just another show
to go on and so
as soon as they turn against me and like
sharon made fun of me and how he made
fun of me and then howard was the last
one
then i flipped it right away and
sharon's like this is awful this is
annoying and i was just like
oh well i'm like not true at all i was
just like oh i'm just here and i love
hearthstone and i'll get me wrong i was
like i'm just here for howard stern but
i would they actually asked me to be
honest
here's morgan and so immediately the
whole audience flipped and then however
it's like well in that case let me come
up and dance with you like i'll
have a date with you in vegas like all
this so it turned around completely but
it went well didn't it in the end you
made it
yeah of course because and then howard
talked about me on a show
whatever so you saved it i saved it but
like i don't remember it when i got off
stage i remember i called my mom and my
mom like how'd it go i'm like i honestly
couldn't remember for the life to me and
like even watching it back i can't
because it's so cringy because like i
don't know that person
like it's so weird like it i call it
blacking out i guess dr dural call it
disassociating but like i literally
black out and impulsive was a big
blackout because they were so
the only podcast i did i did other
podcasts that like went really great
before
that i can't even think about it no
but before that i was doing i was doing
another podcast i can't remember like
adam carolla went really good you know
what i mean like i was doing
an yes h3 show but um
and and it was a big deal i love being
on the h3 i love the mugs i wish i could
have another h3 mug
do you have one i don't know yeah i
don't know i took both of them from my
appearances on there but anyways
um so i don't know where all that
do you want to ask me anything i'm out
of material um
you always say i don't ever get to ask
you anything
because you always dismiss me you're
always like it's not important
because i ask you something why should
you delete all your tweets
because if twitter's lame bro okay so
why did you delete all of them did you
have something that came up did
something
everybody's already combed through every
tweet i've ever made a billion was it
racist what was it what was your tweets
which ones the ones that people well
they try to prove that i'm racist i
don't think
that so why did you delete them if
you're not if you're like okay that was
like
the way racist tweet just treat the one
racist tweet there's ten thousand tweets
i don't think that tweets from a billion
years ago represent who i am today
and so i just i don't want to deal with
having to think about what i
tweeted or is on my timeline or anything
i've said 10 years ago
twitter is just it's just it's
such a nightmare it's like we've
willingly
put ourselves out there on the internet
and it's all there
and you're not allowed to change or grow
and everybody's just combing through all
your old [ __ ] especially as you know uh
as edison ray says the biggest social
media
phenomenon of our time that's me and so
people are always trying to
everything you say they're trying to
disprove for more tweet or
trying to make sure that you're a
hypocrite it's like it's stupid just i
just don't want to deal with it
and also nobody ever looks at your old
tweets for any good reason
right but it's like a documentation of
who you were well [ __ ] it
you don't even want to look back at old
tweets your first tweet or anything
i like to sometimes google my name like
trisha paytas like i'll do this with him
like his catfishes i'll like do trish
paid us with the catfish name and a big
seat i told you that person was a fan of
me five years ago
you know what i mean because it shows up
as our tweets that we tweeted together
yeah that is good but i don't want to
say i'm over social media is just
driving me crazy
i hate it and i'm trying to disconnect
from it as much but it's like your job
like promoting teddy being on the video
here making videos is my job not making
tweets
do you hate the videos no do you just
hate twitter
yeah so just delete twitter how can we
even have twitter at all i'm slowly
going towards that it's because i do
have connect it's like a really great
way that i have with connecting people
and i value a lot of those connections i
have where you can reach out to somebody
and message them
like who who do you have the message
let's just say tell me somebody you want
a private message on twitter that you
need to keep it for
you the other day you messaged charlie
because of the whole
charlie emilio no charlie oh critical
yeah
yeah who's critical just other he's
another youtuber and what do you have to
message him
we were in a foot war he was saying that
he had the highest wiki feet rating
and i was like [ __ ] no you [ __ ]
don't because i have the highest wiki
for you i have a good wiki feet right
you know i'm number one on the whole
site
um probably you talk about it well like
i feel like whatever the reason is
i'm number one and he made a video being
like i'm number one i have the highest
rate of any youtuber and so i was like
[ __ ] this is a foot [ __ ] war and
you're gonna lose
oh can we make a foot video for my only
fans no
why you want my feet and your only face
yes
my feet's already on the internet for
free but i wanted wikifeet.com ethan
client's five stars
i want to do a collab though like i call
a foot collab no it's not happening
why uh because it's disgusting and i
don't want to be involved in any kind of
pornographic sexual
uh video with you let's just feed them
yeah but it's for people to jerk off
yeah
so you're over twitter but you love this
still you still love it you still love
doing the h3 podcast
i do i like it a lot i would like it
more than i ever did okay
my thoughts on the one today is you look
just over it like you don't want to be
alone on it like you were alone on the
podcast today interviewing somebody
and you just were like hey guys welcome
back to the https talk about contra
points
the last one the one today yeah people
thought it was really good people
thought it was okay maybe but you looked
miserable well i will say
first of all i disagree i thought that
was a great interview and i really like
her i think she's awesome
that being said i do have hard time with
interviews i find them to be very
challenging
so i much prefer the collaborative ones
like with you and with the guys
that to me is more fun and less
stressful
anything else next i love interviews
like i think i
thrive at interviews i wish i could have
maybe i could host the h3 podcast by
myself
i mean sure who do you want to interview
um
crystalia done where is he
really use
you know him i have his phone number but
i feel bad messaging i don't know he's
done his own thing
he's not he's uh he's in a hot he's
having a hard time for sure what do you
do here's a good question okay what do
you do
when okay like literally like okay
we'll use elix she's unproblematic don't
get mad at me but like what if she got
in like this crazy scandal right like if
she
she was at a party just saying the n
word edward no cove and math like all
this you know
i know it's not gonna happen but like
she messes up big time right
or crystallia for instance okay let's
say she was flirting with 17 year old
ela or something you know what i mean
jesus okay i mean he's you what if
you're flirting with 17 year old
why me dan whatever yeah
you love this person right like when
someone gets in so much deep [ __ ]
how do you do you defend them do you not
defend them do you have to denounce them
i don't i think if it was someone that
was very close to me let's say like my
best friend got into
was caught like uh flirting with 17 year
old or something right or [ __ ] or
[ __ ] a 17 year old like chris lee was
just talking
apparently he was he was [ __ ] really
young fans okay
of age right you would you know i would
definitely denounce the behavior
but as a friend you see a lot of gaming
qualities and you want them to get
better and you want them to be well so
like obviously that's that's the
nature of it right it's like you
denounce the behavior but you
encourage the person to grow and be
better and you stand by them
right so interesting i would stand by it
because so many people denounced
crystalia
well brian callan whitney cummings like
people that were like that
that to me is like that's yeah i'm i'm
i'm friendly with chris but if i was
really close with chris i don't think
if i was like you know that level of
closeness i would probably
what i would say is um
you know
obviously we did we talked about it a
lot i mean what he did was was really
gross
but as a person you know
as a per i said as a person chris was
lovely he was one a super nice dude
right super sweet you know when theodore
was born he sent us like a really
thoughtful
baby gift that not a lot of people did
that were that thoughtful
but he just abandoned his podcast like
just left like
like what happened like well matt dude
he was in like a huge blockbuster film
and they'd like
[ __ ] cut his ass out like he's just
probably in a really shitty spot
like i think it's that's something like
he's engaged and he's having a baby at
the same time so
a lot no i like my stance always is like
older guys with younger girls i think
you're like the scum of the earth
because that's how i got so [ __ ] up i
think it's
like the grossest thing you could do but
at the same time
it's like wow like it's crazy how people
just turn
and i saw that with people in my own
life too that had like scandal like how
many people just like
unfollowing him like you're disgusting
meanwhile there's a difference between
like
um you know trisha made an insensitive
tick
tock and like here's uh here's evidence
of
of behavior over years of him taking
advantage of young girls
i want to interview crystal um okay
because we have beef he like blocked me
like he doesn't like me i don't like him
oh i don't think it's gonna happen then
i don't think you have any chance but
having said that i'm like he blocked you
um what the [ __ ] did you say to chris i
said oh i hate the show whitney and it
sucks
and he just blocked you yeah why'd you
say that i didn't even mention him he
just must have been googling his own
name
wait so why the [ __ ] would he want to
talk to you
he blocked me why are you interested in
crystalia then if he hates your guts and
you ate him apparently
because you're interested you tried to
call me out before but this is why i
don't block people because when you
block someone i'm just like whoa why'd i
get blocked
because he hates your ass i forgot that
i tweeted that someone brought up that
tweet i was like okay that's why i'm
blocked
like i genuinely asked that in a video
like why did crystalia block me and i
was like oh that makes sense
um do you like whitney
i didn't and but not for any reason i
was just like a hater
and then she was really nice about me on
her part wasn't super nice i know
and then um but she interviewed zane and
heath and i'm like oh that's when you
know you're going downhill if you're
interviewing saint and heath on your
podcast like
okay exactly is there anything else
interesting any
relevant topics i feel like we've been
all over the place you know we were
going to do the beauty things
we're going to do them on wednesday oh i
was asked to be on um marshall sports
don't do it you have exclusivity here
with the pizza review guys dave portnoy
they emailed me to be on their show
are you gonna shout out our podcast if
you go on do i go on
you can do it if you want can i go on
joe rogan how do joe
what do you know about sports what are
you going to talk to them about
oh i have no idea they just like oh and
i just know that's a big name like
people because they have
they have several different podcasts you
know it's a whole brand i don't know
which one you're going on what their
their show yeah go and just jordan are
you talking about that's
the main one yeah that's one that's like
no he has one with like six dude he has
one that's pretty [ __ ] weird i have
to say
with two like 16 year old tick talkers
that he's on
bff or something wait what he hosts it
with two 16 year old tick talkers and i
find it really [ __ ] weird
he talks about tick tock drama with
little no i'm not going to be invited on
i'm just saying i find it odd i don't
know what's the deal with that guy he
is he is he good or is he a weirdo dave
portney
oh it's called oh maybe this is it it's
called bff yeah that's the one with the
six-year-old tick tuckers it's super
in my opinion it's really weird and
crazy but it says dave pointer and josh
yeah he's on it
there's no teenage one no i'll show you
i'll show you maybe you can correct me
because every time i see a clip of it i
go oh that's [ __ ] weird that he's
done
he has a is it no it's
it's one girl and one boy and they're
super young tick-tockers they look like
they're 16. oh they want to talk about
me dominating tick-tock in l.a to
running a media and
i don't know i was like you don't have
no goddamn media empire wait why did
they include
compliments to themselves in the email
to you
here bff do that because i know they're
a big name no one's watching front of me
we didn't even get a million on our last
one because someone put it up late
dan let's not put it up at five o'clock
i'll stay up and edit it tonight we can
get it up early
okay okay wait who's josh
richards how old is josh richards
because so here here it is here's the
latest i mean it is popular it gets a
lot of views
really just go and be like yo i'm just
here to talk about
frenemies like y'all can do your thing
every time they ask you something just
be like yo frenemies
number one podcast i don't know who the
[ __ ] you guys are
look at this this you're going to sit
with a bunch of six-year-olds
watch so this is dave the pizza review
guy
this is the guy is he actually 16 he
looks like it
who how old is he look him up i can't be
involved in
minors it gives me a weird feeling
that's richards and there's another girl
who's involved he was like
apparently like a [ __ ] he's 18 years
old okay let's not say 16 if they're 18.
i mean why why is he making a putt
here's the other girl how old is this
girl
uh but don't you find it a little odd
that this grown-ass [ __ ] man is
making
a podcast with this 18 year old kid and
like this girl
who's nessa barrett how old is she
she's old she dates like little honey
not old but she's like over 18.
18. why is this f how old is dave
portney
okay well it's weird i want to get to
the bottom of this
you're going to go on the show we got to
[ __ ] vet him why is a 43 year old
have a podcast with two 18 year olds
that's
weird dave courtney he's a little
[ __ ] weird and i'll start beating
dave with por with bart's still sports i
don't give a [ __ ] just because of my
adversion i think do you think it's
weird but in general
go on but you have to plug this show
more than talk about anything else
well i got asked to be on a lot of
podcasts since i've been on this podcast
yeah
i'm a gateway to greatness that's what i
told you i'm very impressed
what i'm very impressed with um
like i'm impressed that we make money
off this like it's crazy because i like
don't make money off my youtube so it's
crazy
well welcome
lot of big leagues baby no i feel
honored to be on here
thank you i'm really happy well we're
gonna do two episodes this week i think
i think
if people have an appetite for a second
episode we could start doing two
episodes a week
because people really like this [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] this is
people like it sometimes i feel bad
though like i don't know
i feel like i kind of like snuck into
this situation a little bit do you think
i have no
agency over my life a little bit because
like i started like i thought like
dating like the first date with moses i
was like oh this will get me like more
air time on h3 podcast
oh it was that calculated yeah but at
the beginning you [ __ ] up and now
you're bought a house with this guy
it's not my fault you're the one that
got duped yeah you're the one that got
duped
i literally tell them all the time i'm
like like like the reason we got back
together after that big fight at the
catfish i was like ah i had the podcast
and i felt like i kind of was because
like i
started dating him you know it has
nothing trust me nothing i do
he would have i don't think he would
have had the podcast if i wasn't dating
moses
that's just because when when the court
hit you guys stopped talking to me when
we weren't filming hdr anymore the
bachelorette like i never heard from you
today i had
nothing to do no i never heard from you
guys and then the next the first time i
hear from i was brainstorming
i was brainstorming who would it be fun
to make a podcast with and i was
thinking and thinking and thinking
and i was just thinking like me and you
all the all the
podcast episodes we've done have been
really they've done well people like it
they watch it
and we've always had a good rapport the
way we play off each other so i said you
know it's so crazy i think it'll be
it'll it'll actually but i don't think i
was in your mind whatever that's
frequently
i'll never convince you just like i'll
never convince you that you don't think
that i want to [ __ ] you
i can't answer that because i was like
don't disrespect the marriage you can
say speak honestly i don't want to [ __ ]
you
but you don't believe that i would
rather do you understand what i'm saying
you've seen these meat grinders where
they put in steak and it comes out
ground beef
i would rather put my dick in a meat
grinder than [ __ ] you
and crank it myself do you know what i'm
saying you're compensating just like you
called me a two or a one
it's like obviously i'm not a one like
you you overcompensate by trying to
play it cool i would literally
drag my dick through a field of rust and
glass
if i can be so uh frank with you well
you don't
rail people on a couch so no
i can't imagine you being a thruster
well
maybe when i was 20 50 pounds lighter i
could thrust oh wait do you think it has
to do with weight
yeah okay can i tell you something about
about big guys though having sex with
guys as they are
when you're on top it's like being on
like like a bouncy pad like a like a
trampoline like a water bed no like
those bouncy balls that you like hold in
the middle like that that's how it feels
like when you have someone with a belly
is that good yeah no that's a good thing
about that oh it's good but when
you go back guys they thrust hard like
boom
which do you prefer um i'm let me
obviously skinny i've always
but it's just like you you wouldn't date
like a faker i think fat people don't
like other fat people
do you like like when a can you guys
thrust and do you like it if it feels
like he's trying to hurt you
it's more of like he's controlling how
how i'm getting it
i love that because i don't i'm in
control of so much you score it when you
guys have sex
you always ask that but that's like a
job on the daily you don't squirt do you
how long does it take to
to um to refills the squirt before you
can squirt it again
i mean it's like an orgasm it's like you
know how often can you ejaculate but
it's less
the second time you squirt of course and
how do you know it's not p
you always ask me i just because i'm not
convinced because it comes out
can we get it no i said can we get dan
i want to get a chemist in here and i
swear to god i want to get a [ __ ]
chemist in here
he goes down if there's a if they're
pops up
like it goes up i don't care what the
[ __ ] going on that's urine
it's clear okay here's what we're going
to do i want your hemis
first of all i'll find one but if
there's a you'll make it easier on me if
there's a chemist listening
write to dan
[Laughter]
they're gonna analyze the liquid and see
if it's urine
yeah well urine comes out with your
ejaculation like urine comes out with
everything no it doesn't
it definitely does bro semen is not
urine
yep i love dr drew i wanted to ask dr
drew next week what are we doing this
next week i thought you were doing those
on didn't you have the agent doing a
tuesday it's doing on tuesday because me
and you are going away for a birthday
to the port to that one place that you
guys went to oh you guys are
yeah do you know where you're oh we
don't determine later but it's so nice
yeah it looks beautiful but like i want
to be hungry you're going to lose weight
these their portions are like this big
there
well i want to um i want to
analyze the fluid because i think it's
funnier
you have to squirt well he's not a
chemist for dr drew no don't
i want you to bring me a vial of you i
want you to bring me a vial of your
squirt
and i'm gonna have it analyzed in the
lab i bet you would no i'm not [ __ ] i
don't want to enter i'm going to make
dan or someone
ian or someone watching the show but
we'll just put in a paper bag and so
nobody has to deal with it
okay yeah no seriously next time you're
here bring me a viola squirt how do i
catch it because it kind of projectiles
you have to like catch it do an only
fans people like it squirting into a
vial no but you don't because it comes
would you sell your squirt
gamer girl squirt i'm allowed to
i don't know who says you can't it's
america walk around without a mask
you can squirt in a vial then you get
covered and you die
from squirt i wonder if you could catch
covered from squirt
i don't know probably wait so back to
the tuesday thing so we're filming
tuesday but is it
you said you did it with everyone on h3
we haven't filmed it yet okay so
in front of me are you doing yours here
too or am i just doing are we we're all
gonna get together
next tuesday the h3 people are coming
here yeah no
we're just on zoo oh just one zoom so
zoom
what's so hard to believe about it i
don't think those two should cross
well it is what it is but they already
took the personality test
i just don't want our show to start
tanking you know oh those guys are
losers okay we can exclude them because
they don't get a million so who's
who's allowed moses ela dan
and me okay and we'll then we'll do the
loser episode later in the week
as you said the under 500 000 episode
we'll call it it's not under five
i mean you don't have to be rude there's
only like 400 000 i checked it this
morning
you're such a freak how like you're
obsessed over this i
am i was so mad we didn't get a million
views okay you want a million views
here by the way our apps get like 464.
this is only a week ago but like 6 40.
um well just don't add like i'm not an
asset to this show like i know i'm an
asset to the show all right so it's over
a million yeah you're an asset
oh i guess i was being the rude one
because i was saying they were like
losers and i don't want them taking our
show so i guess
in your eye in it yeah bro do this
oh my god that looks crazy you have like
blue chalk in your eye hole
really [ __ ] yeah that's weird i don't
know why
it's from your eye i'm sorry for being
rude i apologize to the people on h3
i don't necessarily like zach but
everyone else is fine thank you
oh yeah ap i like you and i like the
other one so so
we failed i don't like these episodes
where we just meander i feel like i like
when we have a
when we have an agenda and we stick to
it but i feel like i came back to do
this [ __ ]
face [ __ ] that you wanted to do but the
good news is we'll do a second episode
tomorrow or on wednesday i mean
wednesday what time
the usual time yeah the usual time yeah
why what does that mean you're up all
night
don't mention it don't mention it please
okay thank you what the [ __ ] does that
mean
is he gonna is he gonna be jackhammering
you it's my ovulation week
i'm just kidding it is actually actually
is that what you mean no that's not what
he meant but don't say anything more
just stop
will you tell me off camera no no no is
it sexual
don't break it up i'm not gonna talk
about it like it's not sexual though
it's fine it's fine
i i will be here wednesday i gotta
investigate
it's five o'clock all right we gotta
wrap it up loves coming home i gotta go
yeah you better get out of here oh [ __ ]
it's five yeah
holy [ __ ] i gotta go get my son
wait wait we have to do the ad
it'll be so fast holy [ __ ] it's five bye
you